just go to the USC football team and I
said something in there that really
caught my attention I said something I'm
sure you'll add it and make it fly
because that's how you do it Dirac for
80 or 90% of you this is going to be the
best there's gonna be as good as it gets
this is the prime this is the best and
this rant is about timing you need to be
aware of when you have your big
opportunities you can squeeze so [ __ ]
hard when you've got that moment you
have to understand that [ __ ] will always
change if it's terrible right now it's
going to get better if it is phenomenal
right now it is going to get worse that
is just the way it's always been
I'm not smart it's just [ __ ] history
so please if you take anything out of
this mini little rant for d-roc it's
about timing recognize your moments and
strike that has absolutely been the
foundation of my success whether it was
selling my baseball cards when I just
felt it whether it was the Internet
itself whether it was other things like
starting vaynermedia when I had all
these other opportunities but I wanted
to triple down to my strengths during
this golden era sometimes they're fun
sometimes they're taking a step back in
theory but it's all about knowing when
to go all-in and the one thing we get is
regret when we didn't squeeze our best
opportunity so when you're a football
player at USC that is a big-time [ __ ]
opportunity because most of you don't go
to the league and most of you aren't
successful in the league and this is
your apex and whether you're a manager
in a store right now whether you're a
great student in high school whether
you're awfully pretty right now but you
know you're not going to be as pretty
one day I'm being serious now I know
there's a silly [ __ ] but when you have
your best situation when you have the
[ __ ] leverage you need to [ __ ]
strike and when you don't you don't pout
you put in the work to rebuild your next
leverage I had YouTube I had Twitter and
when they weren't as big anymore I
didn't cry that Instagram or snapchat
came I put in the work to build myself
back up and matter in that ecosystem and
now that I got the Instagram moment
again I'm [ __ ] pounding I'm pounding
harder than I did the last time because
I learned because when pattern
recognition from experience you get
better and so if this can inspire you if
your shits good right now quadruple down
and if it's not stay quiet and build and
look for that moment when you know it's
good
pound because squeezing when you have
the opportunity since the key
[Music]
you